what about time travel would you would
you time travel what were there be side
effects H were there going to be side
effects what limit are you willing to go
to to time travel what do you mean like
what what am I will kill person oh yeah
okay what if you time travel but every
time you time travel you got to kill 10
people while you travel
to Well I mean if I time travel away
then I'll be out of the jurisdiction you
can't you can't go back until you kill
10 people yeah so kill 10 people and
then just be like see you yeah but you
got to kill them it's fine and you got
to kill at least one
kid it's always the
kids no I wouldn't do that okay which
would you rather prefer time traveling
to the past or time traveling to the
future we can time travel to the Future
travel really fast yeah no one's done it
yet though technically people have so
but what I'm saying is like yeah but
like that's like [__] not that many
years I'm talking like no it's like it's
like a micro actually yeah exact exactly
it's like the fure
I'm talking like you know several
decades maybe even more several
centuries if you want several Millennia
if you had to pick if there two buttons
right in front of you one of them you
can travel to any time in the past can
you travel
back
no well you you'll be taking a massive
risk to traveling to the Future because
you're like what what if you hate it
what if you that time period no one's
going to do it no what if you could come
back and you can only do this trip once
which one would you go to the future or
past I go to the past past really yeah
BR I just like you'd be so goated with
all the knowledge it'd be too op yeah in
the past yeah I would go to the future
why cuz then I'd come back and I'd be
like well I know what's going to happen
I that's if you survive you don't know
what to waiting for you yeah what if
it's a baron Wasteland and no oxygen
well then I'll [__] enjoy my life
while I have it what if you right away
you sp yeah what what if you what if
everyone's using like [__] Elon coins
and shoving Jeff bezos's butt plug then
I'll just kill myself at that
point be like this is not aure future
worth living for cuz I thought about
this I'm like okay if time travel did
exist right then surely time travel
tourism would exist right cuz I I feel
like I feel like time travel touris
museums
huh no okay but like there there are
museums right museums and watching
sci-fi films yeah yeah but if you could
if you could visit any time period as
like a kind of kind of like a kind of
like a tourist where you you know
instead of going to [__] Japan on
your holiday you go to uh [__] 19
1980s Japan yeah 1970 Japan or whatever
which time perod would you want to see
and would you want to see dinosaurs no I
would that's overrated I would not want
to see dinosaurs cuz I would not survive
um in the past I would probably go back
to
like maybe like the Edo period Edo
period yeah I think that' be that could
be pretty dope like obviously be
dangerous as [__] any obviously any
period of history is way more dangerous
than right now but mhm I don't know I
think it'd just be like really cool to
be like holy [__] that's a real
Samurai that's sick and then I and then
I get caught
so go I'd go back and I'd be like
Hey where's the guy discovered lead tell
me I'll shoot I I'll shoot that guy and
I'll come back what do you mean the guy
decided to put lead and everything and
like poisoned everyone yeah i' be like
Oppenheimer where is
he I'll take him out before make a movie
no but like as a tourist you you're
you're like not allowed to like obvious
interact with the yeah I'd say like Ed
period Ed period yeah cuz I think it's
like it's it's far back enough where
it'll be obviously completely different
world but it'll also be modern enough
where you could get by hopefully like
inconspicuously or or at least more
inconspicuous than say if you went back
to like you know the ancient Egyptians
or the Romans or whatever I want to
watch Olympics number one that' be Hy
the first Olympics yeah that be hype as
[__] IM you go back we somehow have it
on
DVD just film that [__] here's a DVD rip
of the F Olympics DVD rip of the
Olympics a [__] gladiator fight think
think about think about back in the day
they didn't have [__] television all
they had was this one event to like keep
them entertained that you could that you
had to physically go there to see you
had to physically go there and that was
like your only get slaughtered for sport
what about time travel you can do it at
a well but you have to you have to call
a coin to every time and what's the coin
toss in tail that's just fear and hunger
yeah but you die you die you die if you
that is just fear and hunger yeah but
there's odds of that no I I definitely
would not why not time arame worth it
what if your life
sucks well then I guess it is worth it
all right my life's pretty all right so
I'll pass yeah what about if you have a
power but you spawn that monster from it
follows have you seen it follows no
okay so the the whole concept of it
follows right is that there is this kind
of like creature or Monster if it
touches you yeah you're dead Okay but it
moves really really slowly okay and it
can take the form of like any kind of
human being so you don't know
[Laughter]
where you've had one glass of wine bro
calm down
pleas
[Music]
if it was Jeffrey FC I'd be [__]
terrible you know it's coming then I be
like oh God here he
comes
help
okay unrelated to that okay what if you
time travel but every time you time
travel use you you become a year
younger that'd be awesome I could be
like 20 again yeah but then once you get
20 you can do it once a
year so I will I will happily that that
means technically you just be immortal
right because you can just like you turn
you you celebrate your birthday you
can't return to the time that you've
been to yeah you just live it again
right yeah but no you're going to be
you're going to be unhappy you're going
to be [__] living Forever at some
point you're going to want to die you
going to want to get old at some point I
mean I mean some people don't yeah I
mean some people want to be young
forever yeah I mean what you're
describing is basically just time
traveling back to reliving where you've
already lived and I'm like yeah that's
that's awesome which means I can go back
and relive some of my coolest
memories uh the kind of offshoot of that
is that I would just have to relive a
portion of your life everything that
you've already lived that's great cuz I
can just m Max it what if you like I
know what's I go back to high school I
have maximum now here's the next cave up
that's just sounded cool eh uh what if
you then when you you go back and you
lose that year you also lose all
memories of that year that you
lost so you can get younger but you lose
all the memories of every year that
you've you've get taken back essentially
then so you could be stuck in this Loop
of being like why the [__] am I why am I
then I would take it because you would
never know but you might you might you
might keep going lit you just described
reincarnation no I didn't yeah you go
back to a time like you go back to when
you're born again but you have no
memories you could do that too but you
might get to age seven and be like what
the [__] happening I don't even know
you might even forget you have the
ability but like yeah oh my God this
trash taste after one glass of wine if
you don't remember it does it even
matter because your Consciousness can't
register it so if you are never aware
you're in a loop does it really matter
you're in a loop it's just that's that's
just it you know okay yeah facts I don't
know why I love hearing I love thinking
about these stupid draw talking about
super powers no one's talking about the
drawbacks super powers which shows about
Superman yet I I want to know that like
Superman's scrotum increases by 5% every
time he use a laser beam you know what I
mean like that he's got to be careful
about it you know what I mean like I
want to know real [__] I I want to get
to like a latest Superman movie where
he's like trying to [__] destroy
whatever and he's like oh [__] and he
loses balance because of his giant nuts
yeah like I that would be fun to watch
if he Superman would look like a hobo if
he existed in real life okay think about
this think okay think about this think
about this how can he
shave uh yeah I guess he can't yeah yeah
he he can't shave how would he actually
be swole how can he find any resistance
like work out with to have the physique
I saw this online one time someone was
saying this yeah I'm I'm like Superman
would be a scrawny ass dude who can't
cut his hair like all might I I can see
the r post for this already like like
all might right sorry like old might
like all might when he's like shriveled
up oh yeah he would be actually yeah ah
but he would still be ultra power like
super super powerful but he just look
like a scrawny
dude I already think most superpowers
are like overrated if you even think
about it for like a second you can
watch you can watch a show and get all
the feelings of watching a show
instantly whenever you want to like
whenever you talk about something you be
like ah I want to watch Arcane which you
never would you're like I can just watch
it in an instant yeah but there's a one
in five chance
[Music]
what what's the one in five chance
there's a one in five chance that you'll
you'll you'll just forget a piece of
media that you've already watched and
you can never watch it ever
again I'll take it yeah I'll take it but
you you could be like your wait you mean
instantly watch something you could
instantly watch something but I guess so
you could keep gaming it and keep doing
it over there yeah if you instantly
watch so when you instantly watch
something do you regain all the
experiences I don't want to instantly
watch something why would I want to do
that your would be like so much easier
yeah no I mean it would be easier for my
job but my [__] to your to your
yourself it You' be just as you
experienced it like you would have those
memories so basically time stands still
while you watch it and you'll watch it
all but you occasionally will just
forget shows and you can't remember I
would rather have the ability to that
just happens to me in real
life I watch a bunch of shows and then
I'm like wait what was that show about
again that's just me with Isa guy like I
watched one I watch Isa I forget one one
other there's a limit to how much Isa
you can have in your memory I would
rather have the ability to erase the
memory of watching a show for the first
time I I I think what's the drawback
what's the drawback you [__] yourself
you develop
dementia the drawback is let me let me
let me think of a drawback the drawback
of your TV screen gets 2 in
smaller VI like 20 you're like yeah
you're like man I really want to watch
like watch Death Note again but your TV
gets small you're like [__] I got to buy
a new TV again at some point we [__]
reset it I think that's perfect that's
the level that's the level of
inconvenience I want where I buy this
amazing TV I really want to rewatch
breaking bad and I do it and then my TV
suddenly is smaller I'm like [__] I got
a power up that I actually want what is
to be fluent in every language what's
the drawback the
drawback is
that you have Kyan level
communication would you take
it you're just declaring war against all
introverts [__] no dude it's better to
be extroverted in my opinion in one
language than to be introverted in like
900 well there you go we figured I mean
there's been Des benefits I mean you
could still do turns what you like I
mean i' I think we all value uh you know
actually talking and communicating but
some people might value just being able
to read other you you know cuz if you
can read every single book ever that's
more valuable but I think uh that's why
it's a good caveat some people take it
some people won't I think you'd be dumb
not to take it because you can be you
can learn how to be extroverted yeah and
I think I'd be EXT I'd be like the guy
who knows all languages Rosetta Stone
Child's Play I can read it in one
moment yeah totally I take that okay
what about what about if you can
understand all languages and you forget
one a
[Music]
day you you understand so what you get
to like 190 something and you just like
not understand a single language day one
you might forget like some absolutely
ancient language that no one's no one's
heard of yeah yeah but day four might
forget
English you're like well [__] at least I
got Spanish Chinese but no no day 90 you
lost those but don't worry you still
have
Aztec you know what I mean I don't so
what's the F what's the conclusion to
this though is that you just your debt
your debt can't you just become yeah
yeah you have like the best 5 years of
your life probably I don't know how many
languages have ever how many how many
languages exist how many langues ever
exist how many languages have ever
existed probably thousands right 31,000
31,000 I mean [__] great on you have
31,000 Days to Live you know you know
that's that's a lot no that's more than
enough yeah yeah life yeah yeah wait how
many how many days are in a
life how many days are in how many days
are in a life in a life I think that's
actually a fantastic tradeoff yeah you
know every single language just pray to
the GTA Gods you don't forget the ones
that are relevant it's just the awkward
moment of when like you know you start
bragging to your friends being like yeah
I know Aztec and then they come back to
you the next day and being like so what
was that thing in AZ and I'll be like
[__] I don't remember you'd be able to
help solve so many like [__] oh no
you talking about forg getting Aztec
yeah or forgetting any language right
wait so how many days
28,800 yeah you'd have you'd have more
than you have more than enough however I
what 100 languages are relevant nowadays
that it's I know that's vly under but
let's be like there's like the main
there's the main like 20 that are the
most widely spoken and I guess if if you
forgot like the the really big ones but
can you relearn languages no you cannot
relearn I me would you take this I would
still take it I think it's a great I
think the odds are still on your side
you just pray that you don't get a bad
role yeah like I I just hope I'm not on
my deathbed and my like grandchildren
are trying to talk to me and I can only
reply back in Mesopotamia you still have
the same level of intelligence though as
well so like for the first 12 years of
your life you're still [__] useless
so you're just burning languages away
yeah uh you know you've already lost a
good few thousand by the time you're
able to use them true which s you're
like do you guys know
Latin well no
okay uh I think that' be cool that'd be
a cool movie yeah not get on that [__]
you know why am I Shaman cuz it just
sounds like a horrible movie The Twist
is they're all the same language it was
in his head theide is they're living in
a future world where everyone speaks
English